It's been a long time since we came to Lordran.
In the years since, we've fought millions of battles together.
We've told stories of gods and men.
And most importantly, we know how it ends; not with fire, as Gwyn hoped,
nor with the abyss, as Gwyn feared.
It ends with ash, a painted world and a Dark Soul.
Man was born from the dark, a soul that is kindled, flickers, dwindles and dies in the shadow of his gods.
The human form is fragile and death comes quickly.
But the spirit is strong, and it clings to life like only a mortal can.
So, in a way, Man was not designed to become Undead.
Fear of death is what lets us live.
Take that away, and humanity
becomes harder to hold onto.
Without humanity, you could become
more Hollow than Man.
Yet a Hollow who would die for something
has nothing to fear,
for death simply becomes a stepping stone to his goal.
Five years ago, we told nine Undead stories.
One of the strongest man ever to make it to Anor Londo, who simply fell from its rafters.
Another of a sorcerer in pursuit of great knowledge,
who was undone by the secrets he found.
For some treasures are not meant for men.
And besides, even if you find the most
powerful weapon in the world
there's no reason to think you can save those you love.
Mankind will never escape the curse of the gods,
so why not put your faith in them?
Perhaps if we offer up our humanity, we may receive their love in return?
But no, there was never any hope of that, was there?
These were the stories of fools who dared to believe in something greater.
Hoping against hope that their final acts could have changed fate.
[Oscar]: Regrettably, I have failed in my mission...
But perhaps you can keep the torch lit...
There is an old saying in my family...
'Thou who art undead, art chosen.'
'In thine exodus from the Undead Asylum, maketh pilgrimage to the land of Ancient Lords.'
'When thou ringeth the Bell of Awakening,'
'the fate of the Undead thou shalt know.'
[VaatiVidya]: 'If you fall down seven times, stand up eight.'
That was the cry of the Undead, all those years ago.
And, for the most part, theirs were the stories we told.
But it's not just the Undead who have
stories worth telling.
For in the years since, we've learned more about their Lords than ever before.
There are five stories I want to bring to you.
The first is the tale of a chaotic civilization
doomed to fade.
Another of a lonely Lord, who lost his domain of death to gods and men.
And I could think of at least one who would have preferred death to the alternative.
There's the story of a soul that
persisted throughout the ages.
And, of course, the tale of the fearful God
that started it all.
These are the stories that enthralled millions
of us for years,
and it's a privilege to bring them to you one last time.
Prepare to Cry.